are you uh also practicing in your head
sometimes now I'm not practicing as much
I'm more always writing songs in my head
so that's why I like silence that's why
I love being in the empty hotel room and
being alone or you know songs come to me
while I'm showering or walking around
doing the dishes or occasionally when
I'm hanging out with friends or like
Comedians and people just like say
and I'll be like that's a cool line just
like J it down my phone so it's not
always musical it's sometimes lyrical
it's more lyrical than musical now
because it's like for me it's
like there's so much music in the world
if I'm going to write a song I want I
want the song to be about something
interesting and so yeah the words matter
to me yeah and the right work
and can have so much power it's crazy
like we said with Leonard Cohen in and
they're often simple the really powerful
ones are simple and like you when you
mentioned Hallelujah you know he wrote
like 80 verses to Hallelujah before he
narrowed it down to like four and it
took him like 15 20 years to write that
song so some writers will do that like
and then other writers just vomit it out
and it's and it's beautiful like I've
heard that Bob Dylan or jany Mitchell
they're like they're fast writers they
just kind just kind of comes out mhm
that makes me feel so good to know
lonard K wrote so many verses that like
that that was uh that was so
deliberately crafted yeah extensively
rigorously
crafted he just would spend months and
years and constantly refining refining
you have songs like that for yourself or
you fine for many years it's song
dependent some just flow out and it's
like oh there it is everything's there
and then other songs it's like you might
have started it with music and this some
words that come out and then trying to
fill in the rest of the words sometimes
it can be like a square peg and a round
hole and other times it's like oh no I
can you know it it it depends sometimes
it becomes like a math problem and
hopefully it doesn't cuz you just want
to say what's right for the song and
usually when you you know write it all
together like the lyric and the melody
and the chords and everything's kind of
developing at once
at least for the first draft that's very
very
helpful like sonheim used to write like
that just like he wouldn't move on until
like he would just go this way whereas
for me it's just like I'll just go with
what seems to be coming naturally and
I'll just let it be what it is and then
you come back and you say okay well what
what what do I have to do to this now
like what's
needed